couldn't get crazy everything okay in
there baby
I'm an entrepreneur I work in the spirit
of the pimp game
your girl gotta know what's going on in
these
that's the car right now
[Music]
[Applause]
what kind of it says
[Music]
we gotta we gotta go
it was but that wasn't me
[Music]
it's
a chicken this and
everything
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
and be willing to protect the ones you
love by any means necessary
excuse me sir but if you could pour me
to the elevator that leads down to the
freaky laboratory
I'll be out your atmosphere
[Music]
we're on the scene trying to figure out
what has happened
that's right that is the prevailing
Theory
three